engage with Instagram but on interest
that important to you build a community
around things that you know whether it
be pets or cooking or cycling or
whatever it might be use Instagram to
really facilitate those offline
relationships to meet people and spend
time in the world outside of social
media with other people going back to
social media is its original purpose is
really really important and for young
people I think education is so crucial I
think if you're a parent it's really
important to educate young people in
what social media is about and how it
can be used positively in terms of
facilitating offline relations so for me
it's really about engaging in it with it
in the right way it's not about getting
rid of it all together